[Applaudissements]
oui effectivement j'habite pas loin
c'était c'était rapide et c'était
savoureux parce que j'ai assisté à cette
magnifique journée
merci pour ce rôle très délicat de
conclure de clôturer cette journée très
intense sur le jeu et puis d'apporter un
peu ma ma petite pierre à l'édifice
les points communs dans tout ça on a
envie de se dire quelles conclusions
tirer de ces expériences variées
entreprenariale des heures d'expérience
dans le domaine de la science de la
recherche
quel est le point commun pour est on
arrivé à une définition du jeu vous
savez que les théoriciens de tout poil
et c'est d'arriver à ce graal suprême
intellectuelle une définition correcte
du jeu wii zynga roger caillois beaucoup
se sont essayés parfois leurs écrits
font date mais à chaque fois ils sont
contredits comme si le jeu était cette
puissance qui résistaient la définition
à la mise en cases comme si le jeu joué
avec petit robert ou larousse comme si
le jeu était la puissance même du
langage et si le jeu ne devait se
résumer à des jeux de langage à des jeux
d'humour à des jeux de transformation
continuelle un peu comme dans le creuset
de l'alchimiste la matière n'est jamais
une haie et uniforme
toujours en déplacement toujours en
mouvement et si nous étions des
alchimies vivante toujours en
translation jamais assignables à une
identité précise toujours en mélange
alors les points communs que j'ai pu
détecter il y en a deux fondamentaux
d'abord on a bien vu aujourd'hui que le
jeu est toujours sur le mode de
l'invitation on vous a invité à jouer à
plusieurs jeux ou à reconsidérer les
jeux auxquels vous jouiez sans vous en
rendre compte véritablement il y à cette
puissance d'hospitalité dans le jeu
vient ça va être bon viens jouer avec
moi parfois il faut convaincre les plus
récalcitrants ceux qui ont un balai dans
fin au blocus ont un peu rigide quoi
mais il faut les convaincre il faut les
inciter invitation à quoi le jeu
invitation à quoi invitation profonde a
touché ses limites
sentir lorsqu'on est nul finalement le
jeu nous invite à découvrir notre seuil
de loose
notre seuil où finalement on perd les
pédales on n'arrive plus à assurer où on
est démobilisé que ce soit au poker ou
la pokerface n'arrive plus à prendre et
on transpire à grosses gouttes à grosses
gouttes ou que ce soit des jeux plus ou
moins risquée où on s'écrase
lamentablement sur une falaise ou sur
une piste enneigée invitation à toucher
nos limites
combien d'entre vous tutoient leurs
propres limites
alors c'est à la mode de dire va au bout
de tes limites connais-toi toi-même
connais tes limites mais le jeu c'est
pas simplement du déclaratif c'est pas
simplement du déclamatoire ces vases y
met le doigt dessus mais ton corps
dessus expérimente et ne te contente pas
de les penser tes propres limites
voilà le premier point me semble-t-il le
deuxième point qu'on a vu tout au long
de cette journée est encore plus
excitant et d'ailleurs il a été question
de plaisir de gourmandise d'excitation à
parler du jeu d'ailleurs un jeu sans une
puissance d'allégresse de féliciter de
bonheur de frissons à ceux d'avril on
dit en anglais pour le joueur qu'est ce
qui accroît quoi le joueur au jeu il est
accro aux fruits et aux frissons ils
veulent revivre
et bien finalement un jeu qui n'auraient
pas tout ça ne sera pas véritablement
ludique et combien de jeux aujourd'hui
prennent l'apparence ouverte d'un jeu
est en fait ne sont pas des jeux mais
des moyens de sélection des moyens de
recrutement et des moyens de pression et
des moyens de manipulation ne sommes
nous pas aujourd'hui politiquement
parlant dans une ère qui prend la
manipulation sous les aspects rieurs et
hilare du jeu ce n'est qu'un jeu tu vas
être viré et je vais te le dire avec du
coaching du jus d'orange et du yoga
alors méfions nous de la puissance
néfastes du jeu il est important de voir
conclure sur sa nous ne voulons pas
tomber dans une société matrix ou la vie
ne serait plus qu'un scénario de jeu
vidéo et nous serions tous dans des
boîtes à donner de l'énergie
la machine même si on nous a dit que ce
mythe de la singularité était un mythe
justement et que l'homme va plutôt
s'hybrider avec la machine plutôt que de
disparaître sous son joug il y a dans le
jeu et c'est ça qui est plus excitant
une incitation et pas simplement une
invitation et cette incitation c'est
l'incitation non seulement invitation à
toucher nos limites mais incitation à
les dépasser dans tout jeu et si on doit
forger ensemble je vais essayer de faire
ça avec vous forger une définition du
jeu qui tiendrait quelques semaines
parce qu'elle va être balayé vous pouvez
être sûr par un prochain tedx ou un
prochain livre sur le jeu une définition
qui dure un peu il faut penser le jeu
dans cette double articulation
invitation à toucher ses limites et
incitation à les dépasser
d'abord je vois comment je suis limité
dans ma liberté dans mes ghetto mentaux
dans mes propres restrictions
identitaire oui je suis limité oui c'est
moi oui j'ai les boules quand je perds
oui je perds souvent oui j'aimerais
mieux jouer j'aimerais progresser
j'aimerais m'améliorer mais le jeu aussi
m'incite à chaque nouvelle partie à
essayer de faire mieux que la partie
précédente
en ce sens en ce sens il y a une
puissance d'entraînement d'exercice et
je dirais de perfectionnement à leur
perfectionnement à quoi dépasser ses
limites
oui mais pourquoi c'est ce qu'on va
essayer de voir ensemble je vous parle
un tout petit peu de moi le jeu c'est ma
grande histoire d'amour l'histoire
d'amour de ma vie je crois que je suis
né dans un jeu suit n'en 73 c'est à dire
entre pong le jeu d'atari sorti en 1972
connaissez j'ai été un des premiers à
jouer et est entre donjons et dragons le
jeu de rôle qui se tient héroïque
fantaisie en 74 une en 73 et j'ai goûté
aux jeux vidéo dans toute son aventure
dans toute sa saga et aux jeux de rôles
qui m'ont vraiment passionné je me vois
encore en classe de 4e et de 3e
évidemment maître du jeu
quand même control freak un tout petit
peu a inventé en cours de récréation des
univers incroyable à faire jouer mes
camarades de classe et ce qui est très
intéressant est ce qu on n'a peut-être
pas assez noter c'est que la cour de
récréation qui suivait nos aventures on
était sur un banc et on passait des
heures à jouer se divisaient finalement
entre ceux qui voulaient jouer des
joueurs qui voulaient non seulement être
invité à dépasser leurs limites mais
vraiment incités à les allées des
invités à toucher leurs limites et
inciter à les dépasser
et puis des spectateurs depuis la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle le jeu
s'est dédoublé jeu qui était très mal vu
autant de la révolution dans l'est lune
les lumières ce n'était pas sérieux il
fallait glorifier la raison le jeu
c'était le vice la dépravation
parce que il ya ce frisson il ya ce
plaisir cette gourmandise dont on a vu
qu'elle peut être addictives après la
seconde partie du xxème siècle le jeu a
produit les spectateurs de jeu notamment
avec la télévision et on a vu
véritablement des gens qui prenait
autant de plaisir à suivre un jeu sans y
jouer que d'y jouer eux mêmes
on le voit notamment avec le terrain du
sport alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
que cette expérience de spectateur me
pose la question qu'est ce que les
spectateurs peuvent trouver à suivre un
jeu mais de façon haletante
un peu comme on suit un épisode ou un
film
précisément il y a toujours un jeu
d'imitation qui se fait lorsque le
spectateur de je prends du plaisir à
suivre le jeu et si j'étais à sa place
je ferais quoi
alors quand il s'agit d'athlètes de haut
niveau c'est toujours gratifiant
narcissiquement de jouer ce petit jeu
d'imitation
oui si j'étais ce grand boxeur non
j'aurais fait autre chose d'ailleurs
quand on regarde un match de foot on
passe son temps à gueuler sur les
joueurs en disant mais tu fais n'importe
quoi alors que si on avait la balle face
à eux je pense qu'on n'en mènerait pas
large et donc il est toujours fascinant
de voir que dans tout ce spectacle de
jeu il est question d'une identification
un peu et même peut-être plus fort que
dans le théâtre
et cette catharsis dont nous parle
aristote la purgation des passions
je vais au bout des sentiments forts qui
m'anime la petite colère devient de
l'aele le petit béguin devient de
l'amour passion le jeu
exacerbe mes grands sentiments et dans
des vies qui ont tendance à devenir
parfois riquiqui davy ikea is est prêt à
vivre prêt-à-penser des amours en kit
dans des vies standardisés où on cherche
assure adapter la jeunesse à un mot un
monde plutôt qu'à remettre en question
ce monde
eh bien on voit bien la puissance
séditieuse pour le coup du jeu le jeu
nous incite toujours à nous agrandir et
qu'est-ce qui s'agrandit en nous notre
sentiment de liberté voire même notre
liberté elle-même
je vais vous parler de mes expériences
j'ai donc grandi avec le jeu j'ai fait
de la philosophie comme un grand jeu et
j'ai développé le premier jeu
philosophique authentiquement
philosophique puisqu'il s'agissait de
donner la puissance philosophant tôt
joueurs ça s'appelle effectivement le
jeu du phénix l'apparence de ce jeu sac
ça ressemble à un jeu de tarot et je
n'ai pas arrêté de dire on a eu des
belles pages notamment dans libération
double page philosopher et il joue et la
réponse était oui peut-être et sa porte
est peut-être au scandale et on a
expérimenté ce jeu de tarot en disant
pas besoin d'hypothèses mystique fillon
nous au hasard assumons le hasard
le problème avec ce jeu c'est beaucoup
de moustiques se sont emparés du jeu en
disant mais non il y a eu des puissances
occultes dans ce jeu c'est pas ma
théorie j'ai toujours défendu la théorie
que le hasard seul suffisait c'est le
mode d'un philosophe espagnol que
j'apprécie miguel de unamuno en 1912 il
est créé un article sur le jeu d'échec
c'est un passionné de cocottes en papier
il a quand même fait un traité de cocoto
logis royal niveau du mec est donc il
écrit en 1912 sur le jeu d'échecs et dit
finalement l'art suprême est d'ailleurs
le jeu d'échecs ne remplit pas cette
fonction l'art suprême c'est de pouvoir
charmer le hasard être maître du hasard
profiter du hasard c'est l'art suprême
et c'est par le jeu qu'on arrive à
s'entraîner à pouvoir être maître du
hasard je vous montre un peu ce jeu du
phénix 6 à sa fiche voilà alors vous
avez un système de cartes et l'idée
c'est qu'il ya pas quelqu'un qui vous
tient les cartes c'est que voulait tirer
vous même et donc vous êtes vous même en
position dans l'espace du jeu c'est à
dire dix minutes deux parties de pouvoir
tirer les cartes et le but du jeu c'est
de faire comme si c'était vrai parce que
évidemment ce n'est pas vrai on
la part de hasard le jeudi strictement
n'importe quoi vous êtes d'accord
et en plus il est bien foutu c'est à
dire qu'ils répondent toujours de façon
intéressante on vous poser n'importe
quelle question questions existentielles
questions d'ordre pratique questions
vraiment le mec de ma copine de ma soeur
etc ou question qu'est ce que la liberté
ça nous libres quel est mon destin et le
jeu va répondre de façon très précise
car choses intéressantes
plus on cherche à éviter la case gourou
et mysticisme plus on peut permettre au
jeu à être précis si vous voulez avoir
toujours raison
en 10 s de bonne aventure avec des
cartes vous devez avoir des cartes très
flou qui disent tout et son contraire
lalanne 13 c'est la mort seul avis et là
c'est la renaissance
là au contraire comme on assume le fait
qu'on a le droit de se planter en tire
les cartes
du coup les cartes sont très précises et
l'impact et la leçon que j'en retire
après cinq ans d'expérimentation ce jeu
à bamako à hanoi en californie partout
partout dans le monde
la grande conclusion que j'en tire c'est
que les gens ne peuvent pas s'empêcher
de d'évacuer la question du hasard et de
remettre leurs propres religiosité leur
propre mysticisme et donc c'est un jeu
proprement laïque dans la définition de
la laïcité suprême
il n'impose pas un dogme mais les gens
viennent avec leurs dogmes et c'est
l'occasion d'en parler d'y réfléchir
voire peut-être de les amender ce qui
est le sens de la philosophie
voilà pour le jeu du phénix et je vais
vous présenter maintenant un autre jeu
le premier jeu de rôle en vidéo live que
j'ai mis en place l'année pour l'année
dernière et que je mets en place cette
année la saison 2 on parle presque en
saison commencera le 22 mars 2010 est à
21h heure française
ces primates job je vous laisse
découvrir un jeu de rôle vous avez vu ce
matin on en n'a pas refait ce matin
début d'après midi
on en a parlé on vous a dit que ces 6 8
joueurs là on a atteint 50 joueurs dont
23 en simultané donc je devais en tant
que maître du jeu j'ai l'air un peu fou
enfin je peux être l'art fulham et là
vraiment je suis de fuir maître du jeu
donc je suis dans le truc je suis dans
le jeu voilà je suis dans le groupe on y
va
je vous laisse découvrir l'ambiance
alors dois-je appuyer encore j'aurais pu
encore
faut passer toutes les touts les slides
je peux continuer quand pendant que ça
passe
j'avais pas qu'elle n'avait autant dites
moi la question évidemment qu'on
découvre en jouant jeu du phénix c'est
que les gens n'ont pas de question et
les gens ont toujours les mêmes
questions et le chose lâche aux aigreurs
incroyable c'est qu'on commence la
partie en disant c'est quoi ta question
raconte moi ta question est en fait plus
on joue au jeu plus on a envie d'avoir
des questions innovantes et des
questions sur sa propre vie et c'est
tout un art de développer ces questions
allons-y pour le premier jeu de roulage
anosy allons-y on se connecte donné
trois joueurs et on s'est tous joué je
crois valérie tu sais jouer rassure moi
je crois que tu sais jouer puisque tu es
même ces mêmes rêves et a même joué la
dernière fois avec nous si je me
souviens bien et tu fais référence est
ici avec deux points d'expérience donc
c'est parfait
alors comment ça se passe je suis ultra
connectés je vous ai parlé de nez aux
scop
le néo scop ce sont ces lunettes
apparemment tout simple mais évidemment
dès que je l'aimais je suis connecté à
2114 lula dit ok je prends le tour de
nous la vie et elle va agir c'est trop
rigolo ce que tu dis un point de jours
ces géniales comme répartis pour un
scénario malika nounou c'est
extraordinaire malika qui dit une
incroyable manioc riz kit qui me pilote
unacois vue humain génial génial phrase
laïque est là
e
oui tu vois mais c'est intéressant ce
qui s'est passé lullaby
je pense que tu as été surprise parce
qu'à un moment c'est monté en flèche et
ça montre quelque chose de l'être humain
ce qui est fort c'est que on retrouve un
truc qu'on savait depuis l'enfance mais
qu'on oublie on retrouve la puissance de
l'imagination
on n'a pas besoin de jeux vidéo quand je
vous décris le truc est qu on est
évidemment dans une sorte de transe
collective
c'est un c'est de la magie on est dans
une transe collective et quand je vous
dis il ya des nénuphars en verre etc
vous y êtes
[Musique]
voilà voilà pour la présentation alors
on pilote des singes dans le futur vous
avez compris une technologie du futur en
2000 en 2017 nous permet de piloter via
internet
l'internet des singes existants
l'humanité contrôlés par des singes dont
je vous le passez vous pourrez aller
voir le jeu mais ce qui est passionnant
et j'en tire des conclusions avec vous
c'est ça qui est intéressant dans un
bilan rétrospectif c'est que pareil on
n'ose pas on n'ose pas le jeu à
développer la capacité d'audace et de
bravoure dans des décisions surtout à
des avec des joueurs qui ne savait pas
ce que c'était un jeu de rôle qui ont
découvert qu'en fait dans l'imaginaire
et bien on peut être bloquée et même
lorsque le monde et fictionnels et ben
on peut avoir peur de prendre des
décisions qui impacte la narration
c'est peut-être ça le jeu impacté et
narration et construire un récit alors
je vais vous livrer une définition du
jeu qui va durer le temps qu'elle dure
et peut-être qu'il va être féconde je
l'espère avec vous voilà comment je
définirais le jeu le jeu jouer qu'est ce
que c'est c'est optimiser savoureusement
bien sûr tous les maux compte optimiser
savoureusement ses habitudes décisionnel
pour accroître sa liberté dans un champ
données je vous explique pas ce que ça a
l'air très compliqué en fait c'est la
bid
j'espère que ça va être la bid pour vous
optimisez on s'améliore dans le jeu le
progrès fait partie du jeu plus vous
jouez plus vous allez progresser que ce
soit à tetris dans un jeu vidéo ou au
football
optimiser savoureusement imaginer dans
l'éducation nationale
si on avait des professeurs qui
commençait à être des maîtres du jeu au
sens de jeu de rôle
ça changerait la donne puisque ça rien
vitre est la passion sur la table de
l'éducation alors que pour l'or
l'éducation consiste en général à
dépassionner les élèves pour les adapter
au monde contemporain optimisé
savoureusement ses habitudes décisionnel
dans le jeu je fais des choix c'est ça
qui est excitant et ses choix deviennent
comme des réflexes et ce n'est pas pour
rien que les animaux jouent et
apprennent à travers le jeu
la nature a fait du jeu l'instrument de
l'apprentissage il s'agit de développer
des réflexes nouveau et puis pour
accroître sa liberté dans un champ
donnait alors le champ du jeu ça peut
être un champ plutôt le champ de la
volonté si c'était jeu qui vous demande
des réflexes le champ de la stratégie le
champ de la bravoure 6 et des jeux de
cape et d'épée
et puis si vous enlevez de la phrase
dans un champ données optimisées
savoureusement ses habitudes décisionnel
pour accroître sa liberté points ça
s'appelle la philosophie juste un petit
un petit point pour finir voici un an
vous savez c'est que sais-je une
encyclopédie un énoncé crédit en
plusieurs volumes tout le monde en a lu
dans sa vie et dans ce petit que celle
on assure les jeux d'entreprise
on a cette magnifique phrase qui évoque
les serious games aujourd'hui l'objet de
ce petit ouvrage est de présenter au
grand public
cette nouvelle méthode d'investigation
d'enseignement et de perfectionnement
des cadres de l'industrie du commerce
par le jeu 1969
rien n'est nouveau on n'invente rien le
jeu et la découverte de toutes les
périodes émancipatrice lorsqu'il s'agit
de développer notre liberté de façon
savoureuse
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]